eine million und mittlerweile fast
500.000 fans wollten gerne dass die
kompetenten autoren das drehbuch noch
mal neu schreiben ich finde
nachdem ich die letzte staffel jetzt
oder bzw die letzte folge gesehen habe
haben sie meiner meinung nach das beste
draus gemacht zwischen wünsche erfüllen
und nicht so erwartbar sein und außerdem
ist ja auch immer die frage wenn wir
jetzt fans quasi wegen wollen wenn
scheinen lassen wir darf entscheiden wie
sie sich figuren entwickeln kann quasi
an den figuren passt zu ändern und auch
zu sagen ich habe das tor erkannt wie
die werden müssen und da würde ich mir
natürlich sagen dass haben immer noch
die die die figuren quasi das schaffen
und erfunden haben und das sind in
diesem fall ja mehrere ist ein
schauspieler ist es ein
der autor martin und es sind aber auch
die autoren weiß und banjo also dann
können auch anfangen petition zu
schreiben nur sagen die titanic durfte
nicht untergehen
aber die fans foutieren das nicht und
meinen man hätte es für uns und hat sich
die frage auf die figuren gestorben sind
so schon passiert dann kann man fordern
dass sie zurückkommen aber hat man das
recht natürlich zu sagen was man auf die
haut die figuren haben sich nicht so
entwickelt wie ich mir das wünsche macht
bitte nochmal und das ist jetzt eben der
fall
und da wird den autoren vorgeworfen dass
er nicht weiß was der andere tut und
dass sie eben dann inkompetent werden
wenn es keine vorlage mehr gibt durch
eben das lied von eis und feuer von
george rr martin und all das fällt den
autoren vermeintlich auf die füße
deswegen ist die letzte staffel vor
allen dingen großen wenn man sagen
ästhetischen schwankungen unterworfen
weil man sagt immer dann wenn es quasi
jetzt mit final bombastischen letzte
runde geht und es darum geht die großen
letzten gefechte zu zeigen
und plötzlich ablaufen zu lassen dann
ist die serie wirklich groß und drückt
ein sofa wie lange nichts mehr
diese ganzen versuche kammerspiele zu
organsieren vor den kämpfen in denen die
episoden und folge sprach lass dich
werden die funktionieren leider wird es
überhaupt nicht mehr und deswegen ist
die serie die letzte staffel natürlich
einfach schwer schwer auszuhalten es
geht jetzt um alles und gleichzeitig
nichts ist kann eigentlich keiner mehr
gewinnen und dafür schaffen sie in der
letzten folge eigentlich ein recht
versöhnlichen ton anzuschlagen ist kann
man verabscheuen
man kann aber auch sagen es wäre noch
einfacher gewesen jetzt noch mal alles
brennen zu lassen und in chaos versinken
zu lassen
[Musik]
während man dann zufrieden gewesen mit
dem ende vermutlich mich